Jack time now for CBS morning's deals
where we show you items that might make
your day a little bit better all
exclusive discounted prices to start
shopping now scan the QR code there on
the upper left hand side of your screen
or visit cbsdeals.com we are happy to
welcome back lifestyle host Gail bass
for more on all these items and we're
going to begin with Asana you can lie in
on your bed oh yes absolutely you can I
bring you Tidings of great comfort joy
and warmth good today because I want you
to bend over and just stick your hand in
there and feel how warm that is you lose
weight with that Gail if you get in if
you get in and you see oh wow yes you
can this can get up to 150 degrees this
is the calming heat sauna wrap I vibrate
like this pizza I actually like it you
climbing what's the purpose of it this
the purpose is to act like Asana you
know when you go to a sauna you know
Sports guys like that you want to sweat
and get drenched and all that you can
climb in this on your bed on a heat
resistant floor in your home it gives
you vibration it gives you that heat
that you want you can set it to the
level that's good for you and check
check out when you touched it you notice
that it's water resistant so if you put
this on your bed your bed's still going
to be dry after you sweat all you want
to yeah so are you naked or do you wear
a bathing suit I suggest you put on Long
gear and long long sleeves because this
gets up to 150 degrees okay yeah yeah no
doubt what it does is it can decrease
the inflammation but also detoxify the
body oh yeah so athletes use it for
multiple reasons you don't have to build
a sun in the backyard like my boyfriend
did you just gotta just put this on and
this is portable you could take it with
you and it's a nice Mother's Day gift
would I okay what does it cost if you
wanted what's great about this is it
costs about the same as one hour at the
spa we have it for 179. that's 40 that
is a great that's absolutely a great
deal because you get this over and over
whenever you want at the spa you got to
pay that each year and if you do use it
on the bed and you're enjoying it so
much you're moving around and you're
worried the sheets are going to come off
that's product number two oh I got the
better better for you guys
it would our beautiful model lift that
up that's like a beautiful model this is
hospital corners for the lazy that's
what the makeup artist said today
tucks the corners in for you so if you
have a bad back and you're lifting up
the bed every day you don't have to do
that anymore get the better better and
this is a deal you want to get right now
because people are going to see this and
they they're going to say my kids can
never say I don't want to make up the
bed it's too hard you just tuck and go I
wonder how when I'm in the hotel and
it's just super snug and tight how do
they get those Corners in there that may
be what they're using yes and this is
also it can also take place at your
nightstand because look at this I'm
going to flip this over let me show you
some magic boom flip that over put your
glasses in there no fumbling around on
the wood floor because you know if you
start fumbling under your bed and
there's somebody else in the bed with
you they're saying why are you making so
much noise now you don't have to do you
know what you could also do you could
put your remote control there yes
it worked
it works popcorn in the bag
yes in the bag in the bag how much does
this cost this is you can get this for
starting at twenty dollars so it's a
really great deal for you to really want
to get in on now at cbsdeals.com now
these are okay
this was on Oprah's favorite thing it
was a couple years ago yes these are
poodles and what I love about these yes
not only do they have the non-slip
rubber soles yeah they're all right
they've got the faux fur Sherpa lining
which is perfect because in cold weather
you want to make sure those tootsies are
cold and you know you need a stocking
stuffer this is perfect because it's
good for everybody they're unisex and
they fit most sizes and check out the
slippers memory foam no we took like oh
wow yeah oh wow speed or a size 14. I
got some for him too so we all took a
whole group picture for Christmas time
these are these are by the way a great
gift and perfect for a family picture
that's the price on these oh these start
at 21 we have
yeah love yourself live inspired it says
Gail bass you help us do that thank you
very much I try a girl tries and
remember you could get these at
cbsdeals.com because you want to get
them now before they get out that is
true and of course where they run with
all of these companies to get those
great deals Gail was just telling you
about to buy anything you saw today scan
the QR code on your screen you see it
upper left or head over to cbsdeals.com
to start shopping now we'll be right
back